they are in that studio rehearsing and
just doing everything that they can
the Dancing with the Stars finale is
upon us and it's all coming down to
Rashad Jennings at David Ross and an
injured normanni Corday Oh God you sure
I'm just hoping that she is in good
health so that she can finish and have a
good freestyle because she's so close I
would hate for her to be injured
throughout this whole thing I would be
terrible I think normani
or Rashad can have it as a bat I'm
running for a shot you know he's my
friend he's an awesome guy he's an
athlete he's been working so hard he's
been so disciplined and focused he was
he showed a great improvement from week
one no money is incredible she gets out
there I think she's one of the best
performers we've ever had and then
Rashad is so lovable and everyone has
got to know him in a different way and
again very talented and then you have
David who is just a fan favorite who has
so many voters and fans and is really
what Dancing with the Stars is all about
and then that has no dance background
and just gets out there and gives it a
go and so for me it could go either way
Seana Gleb and Whitney will all be back
for the big finale we've got a great
opening number we've got a voice number
me and Charlotte we're doing a music act
it's going to be super hot and you know
we're doing we're recreating a Magic
Mike with Lindsey and David it's you
know Bonner is going to be in
kiyo autumn so it's going to be he's
gonna be awesome yeah you're a body
gonna do there
[Music]